amber dropped a record yeah what'd you  think of it i love it  shots are hard yeah i'm just like you  give her pointers you know what i mean  like she don't take pointers she don't  take pointers especially for men right  but no i'm always i've always been  supportive and like you know encouraging  but if if it wasn't fair  i would be like  you know it's cool but i think it's heat  it's not bad um  give me your top three tips for people  to co-parent out there because i feel  like you guys do it flawlessly top three  tips to co-parent if you're a man get  over yourself  uh if you're a man  don't give a woman advice on what she  should do  take take [ __ ] full responsibility  accountability for your actions  and don't be childish you know grow up  yeah yeah grow the [ __ ] up man